you [ __ ] thought uncle Joey
forgot about you I never forget about
you [ __ ] savages the love is real you
know I'm saying when the love is real I
don't forget about nobody pilot to
Bombardier pilot to Bombardier I can't
see nothing there's nothing but clouds
and it looks like we're going deep into
the murky waters in the underworld what
do I do over and out what do I do
over and out
BAM [ __ ] uncle Joey here looking
[ __ ] smooth tip-top Magoo on the
Lord's Day with his [ __ ] Ben Franklin
hairdo I hope you guys are doing well
I'm checking in on you to make sure your
swinging dick and giving out crucifixes
you know I'm saying no [ __ ]
confusions it's a big day today it's six
more shoplifting days before Christmas
that's one thing but it's the beginning
of the week you understand me wake up
the two weeks that killed Jesus right in
strawberry cheesecake from perennial and
I got skull bones from the [ __ ] one i
jus
you know why cuz we ain't [ __ ] around
this week plus was stocking up because
the weed laws are changing on January
1st so I'm stocking up on my high-end
the [ __ ] reef is you follow me beside
that it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
to be alive uncle Joey here dropping
knowledge swinging dick
loving you more than ever you understand
they had a big day today I got disney on
ice this afternoon with the family we
got a podcast tonight I went to church
this morning I'm doing [ __ ] paperwork
I'm sending emails I'm thinking about
going to jujitsu but I don't know the
[ __ ] time frame and I'm home all week
I got a big week so we'd go to jujitsu
the rest of the week today we focus on a
little [ __ ] writing and hanging out
with love Amelia and then tonight we got
a podcast coming down at you
[ __ ] at 8 o'clock Pacific which
is 11 o'clock Eastern that don't work
for you [ __ ] boy when you get
up tomorrow you'll be ready to go Joey
what's with the [ __ ] here beaten we
came to get down we came to get down
let's [ __ ] get down strawberry choice
a shortcake why [ __ ] around if you came
to get down then I'm saying it's a
little windy here the fires are
spreading my heart goes out to the
firefighters up there Santa Barbara and
the time is fire you know I'm saying
things are bad all over remember Satan
lives in two places he lives in Africa
the other part they're half of a year
when you ever see The Exorcist to be any
of the Exorcist with the archaeologist
he's in Africa and he finds 2ne1 and
here the part of the he's in [ __ ] Los
Angeles then when he leaves LA the
Hollywood area before he takes Harvey's
soul back with him to [ __ ] Satan
Ville and all these other [ __ ] evil
[ __ ] Gentile [ __ ] running
around Hollywood he lights a fire but
anyway you don't about the [ __ ] doing
dick I'm just my family get my head
together getting my health together and
[ __ ] plan it out 2018 cuz remember
like I always say a man without a plan
is not a man Nietzsche said that so you
take that to the [ __ ] bank I got a
plan even this [ __ ] Ivan I plan
everything I fight I plan everything
ever since I [ __ ] read that I plan
everything anyway who gives a [ __ ] about
Nietzsche tunkel Joe here with his
favorite [ __ ] savages remember I'm
with you you're with me and they want to
be with us but they ain't really got too
much fun I don't know what to do look at
me we're on a mandate let me tell you
something if I ever hear any funny from
the [ __ ] Church say mandate a mandate
mandate I'll [ __ ] stab you in the one
men don't go on mandates all right
unless you switch governments and you
didn't let me [ __ ] know for me anyway
it's time for some [ __ ] death here
boys [ __ ] around you think I'm gonna
bother you during the football games the
[ __ ] take away from me you know the
[ __ ] around showing up the big time we
got reef fish from all over the [ __ ]
hemisphere
oh [ __ ]
I did my goals for the dad that my goal
for the week
I got my little things set up for 2018
because why everybody else's [ __ ]
general bells jingle but I'm [ __ ]
writing things down and making the
[ __ ] routes for next year you
understand me
where we're going how we're going and
why we're doing it now we'll [ __ ]
doing it but most importantly how we're
getting there and how we're gonna
maintain that [ __ ] savagery
understand me
does anybody could be a savage from one
or two days trying to be in a savage
24/7 slinging big 12 [ __ ] 24 whatever
the [ __ ] it is I'm through with numbers
young Sam smoke too much dope tell you
my numbers let the end of the day you
know what I'm saying I want to give a
shout out to my favorite [ __ ] these
people clocked me up when I was a kid
stay home this is the Angus beef ones
and this is the all-american ones listen
if you have a little problem
if you sickly if you're thinking about
taking it in the ass
listen and it all ends right now we're
going back to basics stake him so
America was [ __ ] great when we read
means nobody had colds nobody had a B D
nobody was allergic to peanuts nobody's
feelings got hurt cuz they [ __ ] steak
of just a me the meat of [ __ ] savages
listen to me you gotta stake them you
[ __ ] friars you put some onions and
peppers on that [ __ ] with some
Wonder Bread little Swiss cheese made
the American cheese a provolone whatever
the [ __ ] you like you got some more
writers french fries in the oven and let
me tell you something you put on a nice
piece of Italian bread and let ya
[ __ ] bulb bubbles the rest of the
night you understand me
I haven't had steak him since [ __ ] I
gotta say nineteen [ __ ] eighty but I'm
back [ __ ] I'm on Weight Watchers right
now so I'm chillin for a few days but
one day next week during the break I'm
gonna cook you a [ __ ] steak I'm on
camera uncle Joey style you follow me
just so you know it's done
just to give that [ __ ] system when I
was eating these every day forget
they never had the [ __ ] flu never had
the [ __ ] cold I never had dick from
once everyone saw why you blew a fart
and somebody's eyebrow [ __ ] lit on
fire but it was no big deal
that's natural when you [ __ ] a young
kid you know I'm saying so if you want
to be tough again and cut the [ __ ]
you don't need tattoos you'll need a
[ __ ] earring you don't need dick and
just need these [ __ ] steaks this will
bring the savage on you but I want to
thank you very much for sending me dirty
[ __ ] boxes I gave them to Steve
Simone Felicia Michaels Lisa at we're
all ready I make I check him once too
just in case you want to be a healthy
steak I'm suck my dick my steak um is a
[ __ ] steak um
you understand me you eat these [ __ ]
things how they are smoke some more
Ethan I'm in the mood to yellow [ __ ]
up with my favorite [ __ ] family here
the church family understanding listen
okay I get it you had a bad year things
didn't work out with how they wanted to
but you know what get a notebook and
write what you want to happen in 2008 to
2018 as a church this year that's it
when I got to be the [ __ ] redheaded
kids in the first when I got to be the
fat ugly chicken the dance in the corner
with ponytails waiting for somebody was
swinging think we're coming out the box
it's time for another boat see this wind
is [ __ ] up my whole leaf up patois
it's not letting me get those [ __ ]
hits I like you know what I'm talking
about people with the [ __ ] clown hits
you [ __ ] scream that you're like
Jesus Christ I don't even have 3d
glasses this he's like a [ __ ]
Godzilla I feel like I'm Japanese
like that one that's what I'm talking
about and now with it all watch the
games and [ __ ] piece like a savage
understand me but anyway you know I love
your [ __ ] seven days away
there's time to be your family
you know I got no family my wife my
daughter me my uncle don't talk me and
my dog talk
nobody [ __ ] talks to me but anyway
what are you gonna do man you got a uh
there's three people in here life hug
them love them you don't need no
Christmas present bro oh I'm gonna
handshake and I look in here and you
thought that [ __ ] I love you
Merry Christmas and everything is
understood take the [ __ ] take the
[ __ ] pressure off you you know I'm
presently it's still [ __ ] Christmas
okay it's still Christmas tough bro
listen to me I had some [ __ ] hard
Christmases in a rocket ship in that
[ __ ] jail and County Jail
let me tell you something man Christmas
is always Christmas in Y all right so
don't worry about what's going on on the
outside in the inside you can always
make it Christmas what's Christmas
warmth comfort [ __ ] eggnog with some
vodka in and his [ __ ] 10-foot salutes
anyway you know I love you [ __ ]
don't be down I was down this time of
year you know what it does it doesn't
add to it [ __ ] pick up your chin take
whatever money you got give out hugs
give out love and watch 2018 be your
[ __ ] year why because you're a
[ __ ] sandwich and you're a disciple
of uncle Joey and the [ __ ] church and
what our [ __ ] beliefs second chances
you understand me and cost me all those
[ __ ] they're also gonna get a
second chance to suck in your dick but
they're not being down I up okay look at
earlier your son Tony only isopropyl DC
metallic oh you're by far higher poppin
$8 see anyway you bad [ __ ]
eight o'clock tonight don't take [ __ ]
from nobody
I'm just like you're gonna get a second
chance [ __ ] it's the second
chance of sucking your dick and you look
him in the eye on you though don't worry
about nothing I got you
they are they can learn a thing or two
from me Uncle Joe you [ __ ] up but
anyway I love your mother [ __ ]
podcast tonight and Tuesday so you
travel with two good podcast and then
next week we got one podcast not to
bother I want you to spend time with a
[ __ ] oh you'd be sitting there with the
holidays watching podcast like a [ __ ]
dunce anyway I love your [ __ ] a
tremendous shoutouts take them for being
[ __ ] loyal [ __ ] savages to this
country you understand me loyal savages
feedin [ __ ] savages fuel and savages
I was a savage when I was eating steak
ins I'm gonna give it a little try run
seven [ __ ] days if I become a savage
again [ __ ] I'm putting everybody on a
[ __ ] steak homes understand me
farting [ __ ] anyway I love your
[ __ ] stay black god bless you
have a great [ __ ] day and make sure
nobody [ __ ] with you today and tell
them on a sub kick dick you got a plan
you [ __ ] up but you're making a
comeback like herb and that's it all
right
stay black boy they get on me mum I love
you talk suck to see some I hate o'clock
the church or what's happening now